I think the stat is 78% of athletes go
bankrupt within two years
NFL players go bankrupt within two years
after they retire and you think yourself
like you made all this money how did you
not be smarter with it well they never
taught us in school how to manage our
finances
yeah and how to save money and how to
invest money then we'll teach you these
things when all you care about it's
sports so I didn't make that much money
playing arena football made $250 a week
and we had food stamps so I was living
in Huntsville Alabama and eating
chick-fil-a and whatever else I could
eat from the food stamps and so there's
no money guys saved my sister brought me
in and let me crash at her house it was
supposed to be for about a month I'm
once turned into a year and a half and
she gave me an incredible gift she said
okay you got to start paying rent after
a year and a half this is the Reuben
report and I'm still Dave Rubin friendly
reminder guys to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and click that pesky
notification bell so that you might just
see our new videos when they come out
and joining me today is a New York Times
bestselling author a business coach and
the host of the school of greatness
podcast lewis howes welcome to the
Reuben report on man thanks for having
me I'm glad to have you here we got to
get some some some simple stuff out of
the way there's anything first off I
love that freakin jacket I don't know
about that jacket I'm very jealous about
the jacket that's like on so low modern
I love it if clean right it's clean I
want that jacket just a little touch of
life the accents are super clean you put
anything in there I don't know it's good
I've only once a few times so I should
probably wear more I put this on for you
I knew you're gonna wear a jacket and I
normally just wear a black shirt yeah
but I was like let me wear something a
little bit nicer we're an actual
professional studio here I had to dress
up well you got a pretty professional
operation it's clean I mean I did your
podcast in the midst of a lockdown it's
the only live yes in-person interview
that I did in the whole thing we
actually shook hands
well we fist bumped and then we realize
that's just do it exactly actually shook
hands and then we found out right
afterwards that you hit the New York
Times bestseller list for your big blows
it was it was in your studio that I
found a magic happens with us
New York Times bestselling yeah there we
go there we go all right there's a ton I
want to talk to you about I'm glad we're
doing this because you know I do a lot
of politics in here I do a lot of
culture wars and all that but I think
underneath all of that is a human thing
that I think you are really excelling at
at the moment so before we get into that
though for the people that have no idea
who you are
who is Lois house how the hell did you
get that fancy jacket and what's he
doing here I'm a human being on a quest
to discover more of myself how it can
become better and how I can make a big
impact on the people around me and I've
always cared about human performance
I've always just wanted to excel at the
things I care about I think from an
early age I did it to try to prove
people wrong because I felt unseen
unheard on right unloved by everyone
around me and even though that wasn't
the truth that's just how I felt my
parents were there for me my older
siblings were there but I just didn't
feel like I fit in in a lot of ways and
especially in school I was very dyslexic
if I even try to read my own book could
probably be struggle reading my own
words that I wrote down just because
I've always struggled with that and I
was in special needs classes from as
long as I can remember during recess and
lunch breaks in school I would be with
tutors so I didn't get to do a lot of
the things that normal kids would do and
I just felt always insecure and
insignificant in my abilities and that
kind of stayed with me and I used sports
as my after-school kind of program to
say what can I do if school is something
I struggle in wearing in high school
they would I don't know if they did this
in your high school but they would
actually rank us in our class on our
report cards so I was always in the
bottom four of the student class like
purely younger they would like say like
here are a hundred students so I was
like always 96 out of a hundred or 100
out of 100 based on your GPA so I would
always see that number and read it every
quarter we would get our report card and
I'd always see them on the bottom four
and never broke out of the bottom four
in school so it's just a very
challenging time for me to to think
about and that's what we judged ourself
on in school growing up was like who can
read faster who's smarter who got A's
and who got
and so I used sports as my outlet to say
I'm you know I'm gonna become bigger
faster and stronger than everyone else
around me I'm gonna show them that I'm
worthy of love and worthy of their
attention I'm worthy of being picked
first not being last and I just put my
energy into that and made my dreams
around that because I started to get
really good at sports and that became
kind of my mission until I got injured
playing sports ends and then then my
dream my identity you know kind of falls
apart because I got injured playing
arena football and I had I mean this
isn't 2008 when the economy it was the
end of 2007 the economy is crashing I
remember I didn't have a college degree
yet as I left early to go play football
try to make the NFL wasn't good enough
to make it and I had no money I had
college debt that I was trying to pay
off I didn't have a job
and I remember trying to go on LinkedIn
to find jobs in 2007-2008 and no one was
hiring people without a college degree
in 2008 let alone with master's degrees
they were having a hard time getting a
job so I remember saying to myself what
am I going to do I'm sleeping on my
sister's couch at this time for a year
and a half trying to figure out one Who
am I I lost my dream I lost the ability
to work out at this moment everything I
put my identity around to is gone I have
no clue what to do next and this might
be a first world problem but for me my
identity was was gone and I didn't know
who I was in the world or why I wasn't
supposed to be here anymore how dark was
that time because you see you hear this
with athletes all the time major Pro
guys that you know they blow out the
knee and it's over and then you know you
find out that they're living on the
streets five years later all sorts of I
think the stat is 78 percent of athletes
go bankrupt within two years NFL players
go bankrupt within two years after they
retire and you think yourself like you
made all this money how did you not be
smarter with it well they never taught
us in school how to manage our finances
yeah and how to save money and how to
invest money they don't teach you these
things when all you care about it's
sports so I didn't make that much money
playing arena football made $250 a week
and we had food stamps I was living in
Huntsville Alabama and eating
chick-fil-a and whatever else I could
eat from the food stand
and so there's no money that I saved my
sister brought me in and let me crash at
her house who were supposed to be for
about a month I'm once turned into a
year and a half and she gave me an
incredible gift she said okay you got to
start paying rent after a year and a
half so that push finally got me to say
okay I need to learn if I'm not gonna go
get a job somewhere
I started truck driving for $250 a week
I was driving Napa car auto parts for
six hours a day 250 was your Suites 50
is my sweet spot I couldn't break that
limit so I was like how do I get past
this yeah and at the same time I was
also reaching out to people on LinkedIn
finding men trying to find mentors I was
just trying to interview people
personally and ask them questions about
how do I achieve anything after sports I
just had no clue how to do it and she
gave me a great gift she said you've got
to start helping and contributing to the
rent and I didn't know what I was gonna
do I really just like I don't know what
I'm gonna do but I applied for a job on
LinkedIn I found a sports marketing job
because I eventually graduated and
applied for a sports marketing job and I
got an interview my first ever interview
that I got and applying for a job and
for whatever reason I had my one nice
sport jacket from like college I dressed
up and I'm leaving the house at my
sister's house I open the door to walk
out to the street and I can't take a
step out of the house for whatever
reason I'm unable to actually leave the
house and shut the door behind me
because for whatever I was either so
egotistical at the moment or just
believed in myself so much that I was
like if I go to this interview I'm gonna
get the interview mm-hmm and I'm gonna
get the job and they're gonna hire me
because I'm gonna be so convincing that
they're gonna need me and then I'm gonna
stay here for two three years and I'm
not going to enjoy what I'm doing and
then I'm gonna feel trapped and stuck
and I just didn't want to go down that
route so that gave me the courage to say
okay I need to go figure out how to make
money on my own because I've never made
a dime I wasn't this entrepreneurial kid
doing lemonade stands and selling
baseball cards and making shoe
accessories or whatever in school I was
just trying to play sports and so I had
no entrepreneurial bone in my body but
the necessity to just survive and be
able to contribute to rent
and pay for my own food as a 24 year old
at the time 25 year old became apparent
and that was the push that I needed and
so I left my sister's house moved to my
brother's place and started paying him
guess how much - fifty to fifty a month
in rent and stayed there for about six
months and for whatever reason that
investment even though it's $250 was was
a way for me to think okay how do I make
five hundred a month so I can get a
month ahead how do I make a thousand a
month it just started getting me
thinking differently because I was
forced to and that was 2009 and here we
are now in street journey so you
mentioned some of the growing up stuff
and self-esteem so I know it's not the
most fun thing to talk about in the
world but you were molested when you
were five years old yeah can you just
break it down a little bit you know
because I think it does sort of frame a
lot yeah frankly I look at the world
obviously well one in six men have been
sexually abused in some way in America
which I had no clue about these
statistics until I started to open up
about my sexual abuse and started to
research it I just thought I was the
only boy that had ever been abused and
therefore I was worthless I was helpless
and if people actually knew this about
me they would never love me they would
never accept me people would laugh at me
and make fun of me that was the fear
inside and I think we talked about this
a little bit where you know I can't
imagine what it's like being gay coming
out the fear that you might have if
there's a lot of pressure against you
but I think we can you know understand
each other in that in that sense of like
something you're afraid to share people
we don't think he'll be accepted that's
where I felt and I felt like you know I
was when I was five I was sexually
abused when I was eight my brother went
to prison for four and a half years so I
would go visit a prison visiting room
every weekend and I remember walking in
the first time and just being so
intimidated and scared and we were the
only white family there was a lot of
black and Mexican and Latino families in
the visiting room seeing the inmates and
remember thinking to myself after many
months I would get
talk to some of these inmates and just I
was a curious eight-year-old I just go
say hi to people and I was like these
inmates are really nice you know they're
very kind they're sitting here praying
they're with their families they're
having good conversations like it made
me think differently about inmates now
some of them had done really bad things
where murderers and drug dealers and he
liked that but it got me thinking about
different perspective his life however I
wasn't allowed to have friends during
those four years because the
neighborhood kids weren't allowed to
hang out with me so I was in a white
neighborhood and having my brother go to
prison the parents wouldn't allow their
kids to hang out with Wade sure what you
met there yeah so so I was sexually
abused and then I just felt like I was
never enough I was kind of picked on in
school for my dyslexia and learning
abilities I was my brother was in prison
for four and a half years so just the
neighborhood talk don't hang out Luis
he's a bad apple also so it's just like
it's just I was just like why is this
all happening and I think that made me
question a lot of why I was even alive
and I would get in trouble in school and
say you know I wish I were dead oh it
says all the time to the principal I
wish I were dead I wish I wasn't here
and so I think I was just always on a
journey of trying to figure out like
what's the purpose of my life what's the
meaning of everyone's life how do we
find a place where we can love ourselves
accept ourselves for who we are what
we've been through and how can we
discover what our gifts are our purpose
is are our dreams and and figure out a
way to make them come true that's been
kind of my journey so a lot of that
works at the at the adult level but for
the five-year-old going through there
how long did it last and happy how did
you come out about I think it last week
oh yeah last 25 years of having the
story of the sexual abuse in my mind
every single day like replaying the
movie of it happening every single day
but also kind of deflecting it a lot too
and just saying okay it wasn't that big
of a deal like it is what it is it
happened I'm gonna move on like don't be
such a wuss like whatever it's not a big
deal and when I was 30 I was
at the height of a lot of things in my
career I had built and sold a business
for seven figures I had started
beginning accomplishments and awards as
a business entrepreneur you know I did I
played professional football I was on
the USA national handball team trying to
make the Olympics running a business
starting this podcast like things were
happening for my career and on an
accomplishment level but the more
success I achieved the more unfulfilled
I felt inside and I didn't understand
why I just thought okay I'm not doing
enough I need to go achieve more and I
was also I had also moved to LA from New
York City for a girl and in a
relationship I was in and then we didn't
work out really quickly
the day I moved here she broke up with
me and just kind of like a you got a I
landed she she sells she's kind of like
sabotage and she was scared and we got
back together and try to make it work
but it was like an emotional roller
coaster in this whole kind of next six
months was kind of another reaiiy denta
t trying to figure out who am i what am
i doing here what's what's happening
this relationship I just sold this
business and I started getting angry all
the time I didn't know why I was so
angry mm-hmm there's kind of a common
theme throughout my life of being
triggered when I felt taken advantage of
or abused in any situation whether it be
a personal relationship a business
partnership a friendship a family member
if I felt like someone was abusing me it
would trigger me and I didn't understand
why and I remember my friend Matt who's
here right now we we started playing
basketball a lot together on the pickup
courts and the mean streets of Beverly
Hills and I'm sure I've played up super
mean streets and West Hollywood actually
probably no there wasn't a park oh yeah
and we've played three four times a week
and for whatever reason I would get
really aggressive at the smallest amount
of trash shock right some 20-year old
punk would be like oh this isn't this
about your mom or whatever and I would
be so aggressive backed with them I
would scream at them I would get in
their face I would show people I would
try to impose my intimidation will
against everyone on the
or because I felt under attack
constantly I didn't know how to have
like manage it and one day I got in a
pretty bad fight on the basketball court
we're actually gonna fistfight you know
with another guy and remember at the end
of it this is right across from a police
station yeah side of the street and I
remember thinking to myself we probably
played together I'm gonna punch her in
the face right now yeah I let the place
you just dropping things all day I
remember Matt was like you know get out
of here because people are making
threats about like I'm gonna go to my
car get mine people were saying crazy
stuff about what they were to do to me
yeah after this I remember being like
looking at the police station being like
I could lose everything for something
stupid getting into a fight as a 30 year
old man like what am i doing
it's a basketball game we're trying to
have fun here and I remember running
back to my home and looking the mirror
just shaking I was just shaking I was
like wiping off like the blood of my
knuckles I was just like looking myself
in the eye for the first time in a long
time
and I couldn't recognize myself I was
just like who are you who are you and
what are you doing and what is wrong
with you and just looking myself in the
eyes and asked him in those questions
myself those questions was a was a big
eye-opener for me because I don't think
we do this enough I don't think we ask
ourselves who are we what am i doing
what is my mission
am i doing everything I can do do you
think that's the most fundamental
question I mean for all the people
you've interviewed and talked to you and
coached and all that that right there is
it more than anything else I think the
great individuals in the world are clear
on their vision and they they know
exactly what they want and why they want
it
I didn't know what I wanted and why I
wanted it I knew I wanted to prove
people wrong I wanted to look good I
wanted to be right I wanted to make
money I wanted to be successful but it
wasn't for a greater purpose it was for
me to look good and to prove the the
person who sexually abused me wrong
the kids that laughed at me when I was
reading aloud in class wrong to prove
the kids that pick me last in a in a
sport wrong it was always to prove
people wrong not to lift others up and
it's really challenging to constantly
want to tear someone else down and other
people down it's exhausting constantly
doing this you're seeing this in the
political space right now where people
are just attacking each other I'm like
that's kind of exhausting at the end of
the night to just like go to sleep when
you're that much rage and anger towards
something else and I'm all for fighting
for what you believe in and and fighting
for a great cause and fighting for
equality and all these things but to
aggressively want to prove others wrong
in my opinion is a painful Act and I'd
rather just focus on a vision and try to
lift others up with you in that vision
so I think that's what a lot of people
have that I've interviewed is the great
ones find a clear vision they accept
themselves fully they know they're not
perfect because none of us are they have
come to acceptance with their past the
wrongs they've done the things that
they're not proud of but they've
accepted it and they've moved towards
something greater than just seeking
success because success is all about us
greatness is about others success is
about what I can do for myself look good
greatness is what I can do for other
people to lift them up and I think
that's when you transition from just
accomplishing something as a great
athlete towards transitioning in
something greater or accomplishing it's
a great business leader towards how can
I truly serve my employees serve my
clients and customers and then serve the
world around me and I think that's the
difference between success and greatness
so that's a pretty solid Segway for
about 30 reasons to get to a little bit
of your chat with Kobe Bryant because I
think it in Capo encapsulates so much
what you're talking about so I watched
it again this morning and we talked
about it when I was on your show and I
haven't seen the interview yet of you
and Kobe and what I said to you in that
interview was that this was just you
know a few weeks after and
is that it felt like it was like a rip
in the universe because it's hard to
fathom
putting aside the tragedy of all the
other people in his daughter yeah yeah
but those aren't public people that we
know but of course it's as as equal a
tragedy obviously but there was
something about Kobe that it was like I
told you I was watching sports you know
the the spectrum Lakers channel the day
before and I saw him and he was just
being interviewed he's in a suit and
he's got the beard he looks really sharp
and I was like man that guy's just
living his best life that was literally
the day before ha and it feels like a
rip in the universe when someone who's
doing all of the things that you just
described who has reached the pinnacle
of their sport but then flourished after
and started this basketball academy and
a gajillion other things then disappears
from the earth so can you just talk a
little bit about what it was like to sit
down with Kobe and what he taught you
and did he have all of those pieces cuz
cuz literally just everything that you
just laid out right there that's what he
was talking about in the interview and
you could see it was real there was no
BS behind yeah it was a powerful
experience the whole the whole setup of
it was powerful we booked the interview
the day before so I didn't have much
time to prep which was probably a good
thing for me because I didn't have like
two weeks to think about I've got Kobe
it's like it literally booked it at 6
p.m. I think the night before and then I
was there at 6 a.m. the next morning in
his office in the OC and I remember the
most powerful thing he taught me was not
what he said but his example and what I
mean by that is when we got to his
office I think was probably around 6:15
6:30 the interviewers were at 8 o'clock
and I knew I was the publicist like you
got 20 minutes I think she originally
said you got 15 minutes but I was like
please give me 20 right ok when I asked
two questions yeah we get there and the
assistant opens the door for us and
there's a big office base in the Orange
County and she says here's where we
normally film but in my mind I was like
that doesn't really look that good can I
look around the office and see if
there's another spot we can set up our
cameras so we walk through the office
and we go down kind of this long hall
with conference rooms on each side of
the hallway with glass windows so you
can see inside the conference rooms and
then
walks down into another big open space
of more office chairs and things like
that we walked down I see the other room
I'm like I'd only like anything here
let's go back to the original space so
we walk back through the the glass
hallway and the last window on the left
I see it the lights are off in the back
of the room probably 20 30 feet back I
see a shadow of a man like this looking
up just looking up at the ceiling and no
computer schemers on there was no phone
in his hand
and I look real quick double take and I
see it's Kobe sitting there like this
just looking up this is 6:15 in the
morning and I'm thinking all right
Andrews got till 8:00 and I'm thinking
myself I asked the assistant I go is
that Kobe yeah and I go what's he doing
here so early
like this is his company this is his
space why is he here she goes he's been
here for almost an hour and he was at
the gym with his daughter and when I
passed away at 4:00 a.m.
working out with her and he comes here
he's always the first one here and he's
always the most prepared and I'll go
just that moment alone of seeing Kobe as
a shadow looking up and I can only
imagine he was visualizing his dream he
was going over you know his game film
for the day he was planning what he was
gonna be talking about there was an
interview with me afterwards with a
little Wayne who was there so they were
setting up in another part it was kind
of surreal just morning yeah little
Wayne and all his bodyguards and this
whole kuru crew is there I'm there with
one person setting you up our three
cameras and like hey you know and I'm
just like this is surreal and about an
hour about 15 minutes before our
interview so for another hour hour and a
half the lights are off in this room and
now people starting to come in around
8:30 in the office and so there's some
come oh there's some activity happening
and I'm sitting there in the chair just
kind of waiting just trying to like be
ready I don't know if he's gonna come
out early is he coming out on time I
don't know what's happening he ends up
coming out probably two minutes before 8
o'clock start time and the the publicist
gave me a bunch of papers of everything
not to ask him a list of things you
cannot talk about from
passed to his parents to all these
things like don't mention this don't
mention this I mean a list I've never
had this before mm-hmm
and so I know to myself I've got two
minutes to connect with arguably the
greatest of all time
who's just won an Oscar as well by the
way and two minutes to connect before
our 20-minute interview right what am I
gonna say and hopefully he doesn't you
know when you meet people that are
really need famous and you're inspired
by then you meet them in like gosh I've
really let down by them they say never
meet you here right yeah and this guy
was the complete opposite he was right
away came up to me gave me a big
handshake I'm just like hey thank you so
much for being here really means a lot
to me we're trying to get the message
out about our podcast like thank you for
taking the time look me in the eyes
first thing I said to him was like I
just want to say thank you I work with
friends with a lot of Olympians and all
of them say that during the last couple
Olympics you were the most giving
athlete that you would show up to to
other sporting events that you would
take photos with everyone in the you
know in the village and during lunches
that you were just so Connie giving so
as a as a USA handball player I want to
thank you for how you show up during
this times and right away he goes you
play handball I go yeah I love handball
and he goes I love handball playing it
in Italy growing up that's all I did is
a fun activity and I go amazing yeah
it's such a great sport I wish we had it
here the USA more and then I mentioned a
couple of people we had in common and
he's like man those guys are my brothers
like I love that I'm glad we have some
good connections and I said one more
thing I said you know your your team has
told me what not to share I will not
talk about is there anything else
off-limits that I shouldn't talk about
and he said rip that up ask me anything
you want take as long as you want so I
was only supposed to have 20 minutes we
have to thing we went 40 or 45 and I
tried to be respectful because the
publicist kept saying I could wrap it up
in the background and I was like okay
that would be respectful but even the
last few questions he answered was
talking about like his whole mission was
to tell great stories and him talking
about love and family for me it was
really inspiring not only the words he
says but his example he isn't just
saying work hard and I'll work everyone
he's actually showed me as an example I
didn't know if he was gonna if he was
gonna see me seeing him that morning
like he didn't think I was gotta walk
past his office cuz I wasn't supposed to
right but he was there and just that
example of I don't get there to my place
for 30 minutes before my interviews
right you I guess I mean you come in
when you're ready but it's like just
that example of hard work it shows why
he was so great and that was inspiring
to me isn't it interesting that you know
they say the same thing about Michael
Jordan he outworked everybody he
practiced the hardest like you'd think
that every athlete would be like oh
that's the obvious I need to do it or
forget athletes that all of us in our
lives would be like oh you want to be
the best at what you do you got to work
the hardest you got to show up first and
you got to leave last and blah blah blah
and yet 99.999% of us don't do it you
know you look at the guys that you
admire most and they're the ones doing
it it's a big sacrifice it's a lot of
time or a lot of energy in you you have
to give up so much to go all-in on one
thing so I know why it's hard to do I
mean it's like he was up before he am
working out with his daughter and then
he was at the office of 5:30 or whatever
it was her 6:00 or whatever it was and
it's like it's a sacrifice we'd much
rather be comfortable and sleep more and
watch Netflix more I like watching
Netflix it's it's not easy to be great
it's very challenging the commitment the
consistency over time and that's one of
the things Kobe said he's just like it's
simple math I just put in double the
hours as everyone else when I was a
teenager it's the first year he started
playing basketball at summer camp
he didn't score one point in this whole
like summer and this tournament that he
played in and then he started doing
double the hours in the next year he was
like the highest scorer he was like it
was simple math I wasn't more talented I
simply put in more hours it's a good
transition to something else that he
said that I think is interesting where
he talked you were asking him about when
he was sort of hitting his stride and he
talks about this moment where Shaq is
injured for like eight games and he sort
I think 40 over 40 and eight straight
games or something like that
and then Phil Jackson calls him into the
office when Shaq comes back and
basically is like now you got to tone it
down because now Shaq is back and the
east plays different so when we get to
the finals we're going to do this
differently and he you know you'd think
that he would just be like no we're
winning like crazy
I'm dominator than Shaq we don't even
need Shaq you know they had their own
problems later but but he basically was
like yeah so I listened to the to the
mentor that's what I wanted to get to
because he talked a lot about mentorship
he listened to the mentor in this case
Phil Jackson who had already done this
with Jordan and he dialed it back and
then of course they end up exactly yeah
I think the coaches and mentors in my
life have been instrumental towards my
success through every stage from my
parents being mentors and coaches to my
older siblings to teachers and coaches
in school do you do sense we have a
major lack of that right now I mean one
of the things I keep saying on Twitter
and every time I'm on TV now is it seems
like we don't have a lot of adults in
the room mmm not not at an individual
level of course there are mentors as we
talked about I wrote a whole chapter
about Jordan Peterson in my dad it's not
it's not that these people don't exist
but it seems like in the public sphere
we don't have a lot of people right now
that you can look to and be like oh
they're modeling something that that is
the way I want to be something like that
I think it's hard to have the courage to
reach out to mentors in the first place
and to identify like okay the rock I
love the rock to be my mentor right or
or Jordan Pearson for a young adult
who's like I love for Jordan Peterson to
be my mentor and get in touch with him
it may seem intimidating to reach out to
someone how do I get in touch with them
luckily Jordan Peterson has a great book
that you could be mentored by his talks
online his podcast you can go to his
tours you can learn enough from
someone's book - hopefully implement it
and learn from their example of what
they're doing I really look at my model
as Oprah meets the rock meets LeBron
James and I'm trying to say okay I want
to learn from each one of those and
create my own model of success from my
mission my purpose I like my blend of
all three I've got the athlete and the
bran James lobby's not as half as good
an athlete his handbook that Ohio that
Ohio brand that wanted to give back to
schools we donate a lot of money to
build schools for kids in different
countries
so I see that model it's like I'm a USA
handball player I see the rock is a
former professional football player
who's now into entertainment I played
for former football I was former pro now
in kind of entertainment and then Oprah
who just is a curator and facilitator of
ideas and people and that's what I'm
doing as well so I try to find my
mentors even though I've never met any
of them I try to find them and model
them but I have lots of coaches that I
pay for in business relationships my
fitness and health and just life for me
I'm I'm such a huge advocate of coaching
coaching is what Michael Jordan Kobe
Bryant and LeBron James all talk about
is the key to what made them great
athletes in school to now as a
professional athletes you cannot win in
sports in business and in life without
having great mentorship and coaches I
just don't think you can you can get far
but I don't think you can sustain that
success over time without consistent
mentorship and guidance that's just my
belief so I had Burgess Owen a couple
weeks ago who's a former NFL player and
he's now running for Congress in in Utah
and he actually talked about a lot of
the similar things and one of the things
I asked him was do you think there's a
connection between being a professional
athlete and someone that can compete at
an elite level and then someone that can
be a success on the other side because
you're just using those those gifts of
yeah yeah
you obviously agree with that yeah I
think there's a lot of great athletes
who can contribute and then others who
can stay stuck in their past identity
they say I'm gonna live off the past
dream that I had me as a great athlete
I'm gonna live off the money where Kobe
said okay I've got all this money I
could retire now but he said I want to
do something great with my life in the
next chapter 20 seasons planing MBA what
I want to do now I want to tell great
stories cuz that's what's gonna change
the world
me not being a great athlete anymore is
gonna change the world me creating
content to tell stories that reaches
kids young adults adults that's what
will change people's belief in
themselves and the world so I think his
ability to say I'm going to you
these disciplines in my business and
figure it out he also had coaches and
partners in his business that helped him
and guided him and I think that's the
key a lot of guys don't transition with
great coaching afterwards and you got to
seek out coaches and mentors constantly
because we're always facing new chapters
you've got your business model right now
but I know you've got big goals and big
plans ahead when you launched your book
and you didn't have a book before you
probably seek down other authors and
said hey what should I do here what
should Jordan tell me how you sold a
million copies in six months write over
the plan what was the strategy you're
seeking mentors whether you're
officially paying for coaches or not
you're seeking it yeah at every stage
well that's what makes you a great
success I described in the chapter about
Jordan he was an accidental mentor yeah
we just started doing stuff together and
then I was like holy cow this guy he's
changing the world right in front of me
and I have the honor of being that close
to this access like every night right
for how long a year or two years like a
year and a half and and the crazy part
for me was that he never once went
backwards on one of those rules I never
saw the guy not live up to the things he
was talking about how much of this stuff
do you think is sort of hardwired in the
way people are born versus learned
because like on the Kobe level I always
think about Tim Duncan who retired the
same year Kobe did you know he won five
championships himself but he was quiet I
didn't know anything about him there was
no I can't even picture his showboating
or yelling you can barely hear his voice
you know I've seen him be interviewed a
million times but like Kobe you can like
you know hear his voice yeah that he
added he clearly worked hard he was a
total pro the whole thing even the way
he retired like Kobe's retirement it was
very public no it was enormous it was
like Kareem it was a show about dropped
him like everything yeah the whole thing
like everywhere he went it was like this
is Kobe's last night in Philadelphia
Kobe's we're Tim Duncan again the same
thing like all the success all that
stuff the great numbers but just kind of
just was like quiet about the whole
thing how much of just like the all of
it do you think is just hardwiring
versus environment I think it's a little
bit of both because you know I don't
think I'd have been in great
athletes had a not felt abused all the
time so I think my environment of sexual
abuse feeling left behind feeling made
fun of in school being picked last on
the sports and fourth grade I was picked
last on the sports team over girls and
that was probably the most like
humiliating time as a fourth grader of
being like okay we're in a recess here
and on the playground and there was a
dodgeball game and that our class was
gonna do is probably thirty kids in our
class maybe forty kids call it half
man/half half women right and remember
there was two captains of the of the the
game and both the captains were picking
one at a time right you picked your top
athlete and they picked all the guys and
then I was a last guy's boy standing
mm-hmm and then they start picking girls
one by one and then they picked the last
girl this is like a girl who is you know
a glass is it like no athletic bone in
her body and they pick her and they
don't even pick me there's a memory of a
movie right now so they don't pick me
I'm just by default the last person that
goes on the last team and I'm thinking
to myself I know I'm not the worst
athlete here this is fourth grade and I
remember being like these experiences
that we have shapeless and it shaped me
into saying never again am I gonna feel
this humiliated in that moment I
remember saying never again I'm gonna be
picked last I am going to the gym every
day after school and he gotta stay there
till my mom calls me home to eat dinner
and just work out and play basketball
and play this sport that drove me that
experience you know I don't know if you
have similar experiences in your life
where maybe you felt neglected or felt
like taken advantage of or felt you know
in just because of whatever that made
you say I'm gonna show you I'm gonna
prove you wrong
and that drive I think Kobe had a lot of
that drive where he wanted to prove
people wrong as well and then it
transitions to okay this doesn't work
for me anymore
this energy worked to a certain point of
achieving but I still feel empty why and
that's where I had that kind of moment
when I was 30 I was like I'm achieving a
lot I've got money I'm got a success but
why am I feeling all
alone what I feel so angry still like
shouldn't I feel happier and that's what
allowed me to reflect and I went to a I
started doing a lot of work on myself I
started reaching out to therapists
coaches mentors spiritual guides going
to workshops and during that time of a
workshop a lot of people were opening up
about their past and I remember the
workshop trainer facilitator was like we
are going to be moving forward it was
after about a few days in this workshops
you said we're gonna be moving forward
to get clear about what we want to
create for our future but in order to
get clear about our mission and our
future and to be able to tackle it with
our full energy we must clear the past
and forgive ourselves or forgive
anything that's happened in the past
otherwise we're gonna be holding on to
this weight that's dragging us down I
remember sitting there thinking to
myself huh like I feel like I've
addressed everything in my past you know
I've talked about my brother being in
prison and what that felt like I've
talked about being picked on and bullied
in school I talked about you know just
my parents arguing and them getting a
divorce just like everyone else in the
room you know nothing's new here I feel
like everyone's gone through similar
experiences so I don't know what else to
talk about and then the memory of being
sexually abused went in my mind and I
thought to myself why have I never
shared this with anyone in 25 years
why have I kept this in and been afraid
to talk about it and for whatever reason
the environment of the moment the
workshop and people opening up I was
like if I don't share this now I'll
probably never share this to go to my
grave so I just stood up in front of the
room and I remember I couldn't look up
at anyone in their eyes I was so ashamed
of what I was about to say so I just
looked out of the carpet and I just
walked through the entire event you know
when I was five years old I was at the
babysitters the babysitter had a son a
late teenager and it took me into the
bathroom and he raped me and I just
shared the story for the first time and
a member sitting down the whole room
silent I think people were just in shock
to see a straight white male who's this
jock looking athlete big guy strong guy
you know probably had a little bit of an
ego showing showing up during that time
share that story because I never heard
person I never heard another story of a
man being sexually abused whether I was
not allowing myself to read it or see it
or I didn't see stories on TV I didn't
see people especially athletes opening
up about this publicly online it's never
saw it so I remember sitting down after
sharing this for whatever reason right
when I sat down I just started erupting
with tears and emotion and there was two
women on each side of me who they're
crying they're hugging me
I'm ashamed I'm embarrassed I run out of
the room I run out of the room out of
the building in this conference room and
I go outside and I'm like I'm not going
back in there there's no way I could go
look at these people again now that they
know the worst part of me the thing I'm
most ashamed of the thing I'm most
embarrassed of the thing I feel the the
weakest about how would anyone ever
actually accept me like me or love me
after this moment and probably one of
the most memorable and beautiful moments
of my life is what happened next I felt
a tap on my shoulder a few minutes later
I'm crying in outside by myself hand up
against the wall I'm like I don't want
anyone to look at me I'm so embarrassed
I feel tab my shoulder and I turn around
and it's this big big guy got bigger
than me older than me probably this late
fifties he looks me straight in the eyes
puts his hand around my shoulder and he
said you're my hero this happened to me
when I was 13 my wife doesn't know I've
got three kids
no one knows I've never had the courage
to do what you just did in this moment
and it's I felt like a prisoner my
entire life holding this in I'm gonna go
tell my wife thank you
one by one the men from the room all
came out and they all shared stories
with me you know a lot of the men were
sexually abused the men who weren't
sexually abused had something else some
other challenge that they were faced
with that they were unwilling to share
because they were embarrassed by or
ashamed and that was a big wake-up call
for me where I realized man men in
general
don't have really a safe place to share
their shame and it's what made me want
to go down a path of like researching
like how many minutes has happened to
and I found one in six men are sexually
abused it's one in four for women
obviously women face it a lot more but
as I started to write up my next book
about this called the mask of
masculinity I said you know men a lot of
the men in the world are causing a lot
of the pain in the world this is where
you see some of our leaders angry a lot
and in my mind some of them they're not
looking for solutions to heal they're
looking to create more harm more war
more fighting more anger and I said if
men started to heal their past they
would be much more loving and find
better solutions in my opinion and I
remember going on tour about my book and
I'd get about fifty fifty of the room
men and women to show up and I'd say hey
just show a hands for the women how many
of you women in the room talk about your
feelings
you know once a once a week with
girlfriends you talk about your marriage
issues your body image issues your
career or whatever is happening with
your family you talk about your your
stuff all the women raise their hand
once a week right and I go leave your
hand up women if you do this every day
you're on the phone with a girlfriend
you're at lunch you have a tea whatever
it is you're in there like yep this is
everyday we talk about our stuff
and I go for the men in the room a
couple hundred man in the room I say put
your hand up if you talk once a month
with one man about your marriage issues
your body image issues your career stuff
your insecurities your fears your doubts
maybe a couple hands go up and I go are
you guys part of a church group that
does this once a month with 30 men to
talk about this in a safe space and
they're like yeah pretty much everywhere
I went around the country and I said
women who had your hands up imagine a
world where you never shared any of this
ever where you kept it in a deep place
inside of your heart in your soul you
never talk to a girlfriend about this
you never felt you could share anything
because you'd be shamed you'd be made
fun of you be called names you'd be
picked on e be punched in the face maybe
if you shared some of these things just
a mad
now I'm not saying it's right what men
have done or what they do in bad
situations we're not saying any of these
things are justified but just imagine
the pain and suffering that some men
feel if they feel like they can never
share certain shames and I want to
create a world where men can find a safe
confidant or something where they can
share more frequently their pain because
I feel like that pain is causing pain in
the world when they don't share it so
it's been an interesting journey well
it's so interesting to hear you say that
because I think we touched on this a
little bit when when I was on your show
but one of the things that people would
say about Jordan all the time and
especially when we were on tour they
would say it's all angry young men who
are showing up to his shows now first
off that just wasn't true
demographically it was usually about
6040 to you know male to female but and
that's a pretty decent mix and and and
it was black people white people and
Gabe a vast raviel and all that but I
always thought the criticism was so odd
because even if it was a hundred percent
angry white that was the other one in
but they were white too which also
wasn't true but let's say was a hundred
percent angry young white men well if
his message was empowering them if his
message was freeing them if his message
was doing actually everything that you
just described well then that would be
spectacular
yeah and yet it was framed as if if you
talk even if you talk to these people
just just by these people showing up to
a place together that that's somehow is
evil with which then just feeds the
narrative that they've already got in
there in their heads
mhm yeah I think for me I think I talked
about this briefly with you I don't know
if it was on our show or off camera that
I remember during my first book I think
it was I was on Ellen and then I was on
Glenn back within a 24 hour window
remember people being like how could you
go on Glenn Beck I think Glenn Beck's a
nice guy I like his stuff but if you're
one way and you're you're not thinking
that way then there might be controversy
and I remember saying myself like just
like Jordan Peterson his books
incredible you know he has great
principles I loved his book and I'm
trying to just help humanity I don't
care what you believe
what do you think is right and wrong
trying to lift people up and give them
tools to empower themselves to live in
peace to live in power and to inspire
people around them and I think that's
our mission so I don't want to do
straight-up
politics I did not get an essay book of
the things that you won't talk about but
I don't want to do politics I think it's
a good escape this is meta politics way
worse but in a time like we live in
right now where politics seems crazy
everyone's trying to destroy each other
all of those things do you have any
tricks that you use for yourself or that
you've recommended to other people to
scale back I mean one of the things on
your eye to show people is that your
worldview just can't be political yeah
you know if your worldview is just
politics you're always doing this you've
got blinders on and you need a much
bigger philosophical religious whatever
it is whatever your worldview is it
needs to be much wider do you have any
tricks because it seems like everyone
everywhere yeah and I know I'm sort of
self-selected into the future when
anyone sees me at the store they want to
talk politics sure but but I do sense
people it's making people crazier it's
making people angry er you know they
just released this big study about how
depressed people are right now and I I
remember when I started being an
entrepreneur after leaving my brothers I
paid 250 a month for my brother's place
to have a room from his place right I
started making enough money to get an
apartment for four ninety-five a month
and it was the scariest thing to write a
check for 4.95 because I was like I
don't know how I'm gonna pay this next
month but I got the cheapest apartment I
could in Columbus Ohio and I remember
and I never car at the time I was
walking everywhere and I remember saying
to myself I'm not gonna get a TV in the
first few years I didn't have a TV and I
just focused on my mission in my vision
which was creation which was getting
customers and sales and adding value to
those customers and clients and not
having a TV was a big blessing I love
movies and I love TV so I would go to
the movies all the time but I wouldn't
allow myself to browse and see chaos on
a screen until midnight and then go to
sleep with nightmares from the chaos
so personally I tried to I remember had
Marianne Williamson on my show and I
told her you know I really don't watch
the news and she goes that's you need to
watch the news like you need to be
informed especially as like a white male
you need to know what's happening in the
world maybe but you can get the news
from different places I don't need to
watch the TV to get the news I can check
you know Apple news or whatever or get
someone to tweet me something and check
it out and people gonna tell you the
news no matter what right you can't
really escape the news I try to focus on
I truly believe that when I focus on
giving to people and service I'm a happy
human being and and research is backed
science of happiness that when you're in
contribution to someone else whether
it's opening the door buying a coffee
having a conversation listening to
someone when they're going through
something doing charity work whatever
maybe that makes you the happiest when
we're giving to others so we're focused
on self and what we don't have suffering
is the result of obsessive self centric
thinking so when I'm thinking in the
news this is not working in my favor I
need to this is an outrage or I'm not
happy about this because it's not
helping me you're gonna be unhappy and
I'm not saying you shouldn't fight for
what you want in and have things to
change sure but if you're gonna be if
you want to be happier focus on other
people focus on service and also don't
watch the news and as media companies
are so we want you to watch us but I
think watch focus on things that bring
you joy I think as adults we don't play
enough you know in my in my studio I got
a frisbee and I'll and we'd love to work
hard you know our team works hard but
I'll grab mat or see oh oh and my friend
and I say we need five minutes just to
throw the frisbee like we need to play
who plays anymore especially if you
can't go outside you can't do this
who's playing well I'm chasing a
one-year-old dog exactly right of that
yeah but I'm like a big advocate of play
over watching TV go do something fun I
went out to was it I've been in a leaf
or eight years how long you been here
about eight years eight years literally
two days ago the first time
went to Franklin Canyon Lake or park
have you been in this place I don't even
know what that is this is ten minutes
from here it's a lake and nature of like
100 acres in the middle of a lame you
can't see the city it's literally in the
middle of Mulholland Raj never heard of
this place it's unbelievable I saw a
photo of an audience we got a lake then
we got a lake and like ducks and turtles
and everything and I went there on
Sunday with my girlfriend and our dog it
was just like we're in nature we're
hanging out I'm not watching TV I'm not
on social media I'm a big salsa dancer
I love slowly for 15 years of my salsa
dancing around the world I play guitar I
like to play sports workout I'm just
like go do something that's going to
contribute and benefit your life and
contribute and benefit someone else's
life when you do those things you're
gonna be a better person I'm learning
Spanish I'm trying all these different
things that get me away from the train
wreck of the news so that did I
recommend don't assess yourself into
what's not working for you go be the
change do you sense that right now
because of Corona protests because
everything is is so seemingly chaotic
that people are becoming more receptive
to the type of stuff you're talking
about because I can just for me like I
started gardening I started doing this
well I'll show you when we get we got a
ton of we're growing a ton of great
stuff carrots man I got real carrots I
got I got tomatoes I got cucumbers I got
zucchini I got broccoli peppers but like
I started doing that I'm cooking a lot
more David usually cooks a ton but now
I'm barbecuing all the time and like I'm
refining some skills and like I think
there's a unique opportunity in this
mess to either come out of it more
skilled more refined more passionate
about what you do or or maybe realize
that what you were doing before isn't
what you want to do or all that stuff
yeah versus some people that I think are
just gonna have slogged through it and
not really thought about their life
critically enough and then they'll just
be on the other side and the world would
be different I'm on both sides here all
right if you if you need to take a pause
and rest for these last three months
because you've been go go go go go none
stop for ten years and you had never
taken a pause in your life this is the
most beautiful time for you to sit
around and do
thing and read a book and lounge and not
hustle so for some people I think that
is what you need and personally my
philosophy is I feel like this is what
the world needed in general is for us to
take a pause with technology being so
fast with us on social media most people
on their phones 6 7 8 hours a day and a
lot of social media it's like what are
we consuming our time with it's not what
we're supposed to be doing all day
pretty sure it's not making us happier
it's not make us happier it's making us
more neurotic if like I need more likes
any more followers I mean what's
happening in the news it's just it's
craziness and so for some I think don't
do anything and that's what you need you
need to reevaluate why your life isn't
working why this relation I'm seeing so
many people not sure if you're seeing
this a lot of big personalities are
posting we're getting a divorce
we're going through a breakup you're
finally evaluating your relationship
you're trapped in houses soon every
minute three months you can't stop go
and do it do I like this guy can't
escape anymore so I think people are
getting clear on what they want yeah cuz
they haven't been clear for a long time
maybe partly but not fully so for some
people you need a pause you need a break
you need to evaluate you need to take
inventory of everything in your life and
create a new game plan moving forward
you need to find some coaches and
mentors and have a game plan and go take
action for other people I'm kind of in
the middle I feel like I've hustled more
my business I've hired more people I've
been like more creative than ever but
I'm also going to the park and relaxing
with my girlfriend my dog and the
weekends which I would never do and I'm
taking that time to be in nature so I
feel like I'm trying to do both and
bounce my personal life but then work
going kind of all in and getting clear
or like what is our audience need right
now what does our customers need what do
they need for the next five to ten years
if this doesn't change so I'm a little
in the middle and I have empathy for
both sides but I think if you can
rediscover what you want to do in your
life and who you want to become whether
you take action on it now or just
discover it now that's what we should be
doing how do you decide how much stuff
to put out there in the midst of all
this because a lot of what you're
talking about is to ease up on this
stuff go live your life get out there in
nature etc etc I think I mentioned to
you last time like people say to me Dave
why don't you do an
interview everyday doing five interviews
a week do seven interviews a week and we
do one or two and I'd have you do some
other stuff and I it's not for a lack of
time but it really in many ways for a
respect of my audience people sorry yeah
like it cuz I it's like if you listen to
me then hopefully you listen to one of
your episodes maybe you listen to Sam
Harris or Joe Rogan or whatever it's
like I want you to that that's great if
you give a couple hours a week to this
stuff that's fantastic but I don't want
you to give 40 hours of your week I
don't even want you to give 20 hours of
your week to new to this so I think it's
important what we're doing it's valuable
what we're doing yeah but how do you
decide like what's enough and what's too
much I look at either three factors one
is like what is my audience what I think
my audience wants and my intuitive side
of what I think they're gonna want or
need what works for me personally like
do I don't wanna be on every day doing
an interview either it's it's a lot of
energy what personally works for my life
my lifestyle my vision for the future
and then what does the data say and I
know you're probably very data driven as
well with your team at least if you have
to be got to be if you're in the media
business so we're looking at how can we
create content on certain platforms more
and less than other platforms based on
the data so kind of thinking of those
three things my personal energy and time
intuitively what I think my onus needs
and what's the data saying and we're
making decisions based on that I think
we did it all here well you know what I
got one more where I'm going to loosely
quote a pretty decent interviewer what
what is greatness to you greatness to me
it has changed over the years and I
think it'll always evolve and change
until we find kind of our true purpose
and mission for me currently in the
moment it's discovering your unique
talents and gifts that you were born
with developing those in the pursuit of
your dreams and in that pursuit making
an impact on the people around you I
think we do that that we figure out who
we are what our talents are and
cultivate them we go pursue the thing
that brings us a lot of joy and we make
other people happy and impact it around
us in a positive way I feel like that's
greatness plus we're in a great jacket
clean your buyers remorse now it's at
Lewis house on Twitter if you'd like to
be inspired motivated and educated by
some of the most successful people
around the world check out the school of
greatness full episode playlist right
over here and if you'd like to see Louis
houses interview with me click right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell